it is an odd thing i remember look if i
was in high school and some guy goes i'm
going to be a wrestler i'd i think
everybody would make fun of him
they'd laugh at him i'm going to be a
big actor in hollywood
yeah rose bomb you're you know but that
and and the funny thing is like you're
laughing but i mean look
you went and did it so you might
understand like it was years later but
when i read uh
arnold schwarzenegger's book and he was
talking about how when he grew up in
the little village in grotz austria or
whatever it was and he was telling
everybody that he was going to be
the greatest bodybuilder of all time and
the biggest movie star of all time like
what are you talking like a bodybuilder
movie star you live in grass like
wrestler rock star like you live in
winnipeg how are you going to do that
like that's just stupid
so i always kind of got a laugh of why
does everybody care
so much about what i want to do worry
about your own and just kind of let
me do my thing i
got really thick skin early on because
of that
so even now here we are 30 years later
um when i come up with new ideas or
projects and things that i do people
don't laugh anymore because
once you've done it they're kind of like
well geez he's kind of dangerous now
but in my mind i still have to have this
attitude of like this
this can't happen you just gotta roll
with it stick with it and don't give up
uh because you can do it but it's never
easy but it's always attainable for the
most part
were you always fearless or like growing
up
you know first of all you were probably
a big kid right i look back and i see
some old videos like you
you had size to you right well not
really though like for now i do
but if you think about 1990 about 511
that was probably 190 pounds i had a
good muscle shape to me but back in
those time
times wrestling was all about hulk hogan
and ultimate warrior and
you know those type of guys that were
you know andre the giant
the big john stud jake the snake you
know you steal these guys and they're
legit
six five six six six seven like that was
just the style
and a guy like bret hart was considered
a small guy he was regulated to tag
teams at that time
and meanwhile he's six foot one probably
two
thirty so i wasn't i wasn't big for the
time it was actually very small
for wrestling now i'm not because the
business changed over the years to where
smaller guys and more
exciting wrestling and sizes that matter
as much now but back then
you could be the drizzling shits but if
you were six foot eight 300 pounds with
you know
jacked up you would get a shot right
it's it's not like that anymore so
but that's when i realized when i first
got it started like i'll never be the
biggest guy
on the show but i can work on having the
biggest character the biggest
personality and the biggest charisma
and kind of stick with that which then
enabled me to get a foothold
and then when i first started traveling
overseas to japan and mexico
in the early 90s 92 93 94 that's the
first time where
i was working with other guys my size
were smaller than me and that's where
size
really didn't mean anything you had to
be in shape but if you were
five foot eleven or six foot five or
five foot six it didn't make a
difference
so all of that kind of it was like it's
kind of the journey to get to this point
where you're
you're learning and seeing these
different styles
and these different ways of doing things
because you're able to do it around the
world and see that wrestling's
not just this wrestling's is many things
to many people
just like acting is or music or stand-up
comedy or it's all about the talent that
you have
not so much what your look is because
you can always
fit into certain areas but do you have
the talent to be able to do that you
know